welcome to this video move it oops a bit
late here
GM Jasper Jasper Jasper all or somewhat
no last card some just for assaults and
I am I think all right so dry master
counsel from Sweden we get a1 b3
Larsen's opening and I know this looks
completely wacky but this is exactly how
this line is played Bishop d6 95 it's
it's a bit strange but it's in fact
quite quite playable for black what is
right now I only know it up to 95 and
the night is really a strange PCM might
play deform no before yeah well how do I
get this piece of the plane
I think c6 is actually normal but this
now looks decidedly strange b6 might be
17
it's very ugly light a 395 this is what
I know about this this opening which as
it turns out is not enough now I have
the really strange position night on b7
yeah tell us the great German chest
pioneer of the turn of the 19th to 20th
century said that nights are always bad
on B 3 and B 6 which is very often the
case that we very rarely well-placed
there but one thing that he didn't
mention but which is really true
fianchetto would know it's on B 7 or D 7
I've really really really really strange
pieces the only thing that gives me some
hope is that he's spending really lots
of time and it's not so clear for what
exactly I would just expect castles or
default okay
you just took to cover these three this
isn't modest smooth okay but I can
hardly play without castles so how do I
actually tidy up my position I could try
to move this Bishop and then move the D
pawn oh I didn't I thought I only I all
reef lyric ignores the movement on the
kingside and I thought yet castled hmm
yeah this is a cool cool idea well our
play in the center
I mean all this night a five and then
stuff isn't really a classical classical
chess but I still like to have some
pawns in the center hmm yeah interesting
yeah it's not easy to blame I'd like to
play d5 possible cutting cutting the
bishop off okay maybe maybe a for
something I'm not I'm not sure and not
really convinced that this kingside play
is such a great idea Hawaiian I think
with conventional play would have had
them a nice position but it's
interesting of course now he's playing
in the center ok yeah he's attacking c6
I know quite funny but this should be a
6 and b5 is what I'm trying to do
nights are not so bad young Atlas is
taking some time I was still down on the
clock though
I can also consider and yeah the right
moment to take on e5 especially if I
manage to to keep the b2 Bishop out of
plane taking and preventing him to push
e6 or something could be an area is
taking ages really ages I mean I I I'm
the Taurus is slow but this is taking it
to extremes yeah I cannot so I cannot
tolerate this need to take okay if I
take now and play you know he's got my
deform
yeah I can always take actually maybe
knight c6 huh he can play 96 mmm and
then takes on different yeah it's not so
clam 96 96 takes takes Bishop takes
Queen d6 then the Queen age - wow this
guy's this is insane
his use of time really even more crazy
than what I'm doing
pokémon are you never going to make me
40 here okay so on I will I will just
hack this off get rid of this this piece
okay we have on that steak
okay Bishop a 3m this is some this is a
point but I can take you five of them so
it's not just not so dangerous and my
ideas to play Knight to e6
yeah whoops
I thought the rook is saying it isn't
hanging yeah that's stupid I really
forgot about that I thought the book was
saying Kim
you know it's still not not so clear I
get no what is he doing come on you need
to at least gain some speed to know the
check check Anoop c8 you know this is
some white boy it's hard time a disguise
simply taking taking far too long
Oh Queen d3 was much better very very
bad I can just I could just pick up the
rook I was a bit hypnotized by him by
the clock
I must admit yeah this was a very wacky
opening I know that this Bishop d6 line
this is a very popular line against this
opening and I know that all night 83 95
is the right one but after this I'm not
not entirely sure there is not b5 so
maybe I should play Bishop e7 this is
maybe better
so that at the right moment and still
have d6 available yeah well this this is
really a strange piece on a5 law maybe
it's not it's not that terrible but why
this is certainly better this is just so
ugly but I'm not sure about about the
Steve three rook g1 business I thought
this is very natural trying to open up
the position after you fall you have a
choice maybe even this one is
interesting intending Knight f5 but
that's debatable we can just drop back
as one you know but maybe this isn't so
terrible I can I can go back and go for
d5 yeah but it looks very strange denied
only seven can be good really yeah I
didn't really notice this move I just
was just playing what I thought and it
looks normal
yeah I overlooked that that the rukia is
protected so I don't really need to do
that I have other possibilities rook c8
for example this is someone better I
have this idea
yeah very complicated but it was all
distorted by the fact that he simply
took so long that he is never going to
make any substantial amount who it
simply didn't get any faster
very strange alright thanks for watching